over the years computer-generated
effects have become an increasingly
crucial tool in Hollywood's arsenal but
there's a right way and a wrong way to
handle them while some movies use CGI as
a gentle paintbrush others have
clobbered audiences over the head with
resulting in big-budget disappointment
not all the movies in this list are
clunkers but if the digital effects were
a little bit better they might have been
better received here are some movies
that were all but ruined by their
special effects I am Legend this 2007
movie put Will Smith as the lone
survivor of a zombie ruled world aside
from his trusty canine Smith spends the
first 40 minutes of the movie totally
alone then the dark seeker show up and
ruin everything
director Francis Lawrence didn't intend
to use CGI for the dark seekers he
wanted to rely on actors and practical
effects but when it came time to shoot
the movie the effects weren't convincing
with no time to make corrections he had
to resort the CGI he would later
describe the CGI compromise as a major
disappointment in a conversation with
den of geek when I saw the dailies I
broke out into a cold sweat they were
very pale and covered in this chalky
powder to protect their skin which was a
really interesting concept but it looked
like a bunch of mime artists running
across Washington Square Park it didn't
work at all the thing John Carpenter's
The Thing is a masterpiece of practical
effects with body horror sequences that
still look frightening ly good to this
day the same cannot be said for the
things 2011 prequel while the filmmakers
work to make the story fit with
carpenter's penology the movie special
effects don't hold a candle to what the
1982 version accomplished
that's not to say they didn't try the
production hired special effects house
studio adi to bring the GUI gross
monsters to life unfortunately due to
problems with scheduling and budget many
of the company's practical effects
didn't show up in the movie
according to Bloody Disgusting the film
was such a disaster that studio adi
later fan funded a film called harbinger
down which was made as an apology for
what happened in 2011 tron legacy the
majority of the special effects in the
2010 Tron sequel are pretty great except
for the CGI face of a young Jeff Bridges
as the movies villain clue despite best
efforts the D aged bridges looked off a
Time magazine review summed up the
issues saying he looks just like young
bridges if young bridges had had way too
much plastic surgery so it's hard to
take him seriously Clues seems more like
an unfortunate Botox victim than a
dastardly despot Green Lantern before
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds suited up for DC
as Hal Jordan aka Green Lantern the
first film in a planned franchise for
the glowing green hero those plans
didn't pan out people came to see the
Green Lantern but what they got was
mostly green screen while Reynolds told
Yahoo movies that the script was to
blame for the film's failure the
mediocre wall-to-wall CGI didn't help a
review from screen crush went in on the
movies fatal flaws saying almost nothing
on screen is real up to and including
the sense of adventure it's just a bunch
of digital stuff
shooting other digital stuff and some of
that digital stuff looks really bad
[Music]
the Matrix Reloaded in 1999 The Matrix
was a special-effects marvel but when
the Matrix Reloaded hit theaters just a
few years later CGI took the driver's
seat the hi-tech wirework and practical
effects that made the original so
jaw-dropping were washed out in a sea of
CGI that looked iffy and aged poorly
this issue is most apparent during the
movie's infamous burly brawl scene a
sequence that found Keanu Reeves neo
battling hundreds of agent Smith's the
concept probably jumped off the page but
the finished product of the burly brawl
is really more of a mushy mess The Mummy
Returns when the sequel to The Mummy hit
theaters in 2001 digital effects were
still very much in their infancy but
that didn't stop this movie from leaning
into the spectacle like a cake that
isn't quite done cooking yet the effects
look rubbery and half-baked and they've
aged even more poorly than the mummy
itself this was Dwayne Johnson's first
foray into the big-budget world of
blockbuster movies being introduced as
the villainous Scorpion King
unfortunately the People's Champ ended
up looking more like a video game
villain when he showed up for his
climactic fight scene it would have been
impressive on the PlayStation 2 but on
the big screen not even close
Hulk angley's character-driven take on
the Hulk has its supporters but the
movie special effects are far from
incredible the dissolve discussing the
Marvel movie noted that the effects used
to create the Hulk kept hitting the
limits of what 2003 CGI could accomplish
making the monster looked more like a
work of animation than green flesh and
blood when Lee's Hulk hit theaters the
MCU was just a twinkle in Marvel's eye
Lee did the best with what he had but at
the end of the day Hulk screams ient
left us pining for the good old days of
Lou Ferrigno and all his body painted
glory at least that getup felt real
well sort of thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]